now when we're talking about insulin
we're talking about your ability to lose
weight because if the insulin is too
high you're not losing any weight so the
goal is to keep your insulin at the
lowest level possible so most people
know that sugars and carbs and excessive
protein can increase insulin but they
may not know the only carbohydrate that
will not increase insulin is fiber I'm
talking about the fiber from leafy
greens non-starchy leafy greens so
anytime you're on keto you don't need to
count those carbs from leafy greens
simply because it has so much fiber in
fiber doesn't affect insulin now there
is one last thing that won't affect
insulin and that is pure fat as in pure
olive oil as an example so one cool
thing about extra virgin olive oil on
your salads it just increases the
nutrients I'm talking about potassium
magnesium folate vitamin C and many
other powerful phytonutrients in the
extra virgin olive oil